And.
Thank you.
Hey, Sir.
Hello.
All right, you guys want to kick it off?
Tell us all about bridging.
Yeah,
so I'm a little bit annoyed that I've
lost access to to my Replid prototype
that I had built because I think it would
have provided a much cleaner kind of.
Discussion, you know, visual.
But I mean it, Jeremy,
in it's most simplistic form, right?
Right now we receive real-world data,
whether it's our own internal vendor data.
Whether it's through, you know,
bring your own data where a client is is
providing us the data,
we bridge it back to, you know,
our MMIT plan IDs.
Right now the process is, you know,
first it goes through kind of an
automated bridging process,
which in many cases is probably, you know,
kind of a fuzzy look up where it's
looking for, hey, I see the word.
Aetna in a couple places I see in this
particular ID there might be something
like, you know,
NY Medi or something along those lines in
the IDs or somewhere in the naming
convention or whatever,
which leads us to believe.
This is something like New York Medicare
or New York Medicaid, I should say. Um.
And ultimately what we're trying to do is
improve that automated bridging and then
also look at are there areas where we can
use something like you know.
A I to not only, you know,
suggest bridging,
but look at it and say something like,
you know, this plan or this particular,
you know, record, right?
We can bridge this to our MMIT plan ID or
multiple in some cases MMIT plan IDs with
you know,
75% certainty or or or something along
those lines.
And and I feel like,
you know that there there'd be,
it'd be two-fold here.
It would be a concept of, hey,
we've bridged this before,
so we know that this is, you know,
we've seen this record.
We've previously bridged it.
We're automatically going to bridge it
this time or we've never seen this record
before.
We're going to analyze the data coming in.
We're going to compare it to, you know,
our existing databases and we are going
to say this is a one-to-one, meaning,
you know, this record.
Bridges directly to an MMIT plan or this
is a one to many right where it it
bridges from one record to many MMIT plan
IDs.
Within,
let's say a certain geography or or or
whatnot. So quick pause there,
give you an opportunity to ask some
questions.
Yeah.
So let me just sort of repeat back what I
heard to make sure we're on the same page.
So essentially there's a funnel. So, OK,
Yep.
let me back in one step further.
So we receive a piece of RWD data.
So when you say that, I'm thinking,
I've mostly heard this talked about in
the context of claims.
Are we talking about things other than
Yep, Yep. Yeah. Claims RX's.
So generally that format.
claims?
In some cases we actually just get
planned lists,
meaning you know we'll get something like
a on the pharmacy side specifically we
OK.
may get a.
File that has a bin, a group,
a PCN number,
which I'm sure or I think you're probably
familiar with what that is, right.
That's on a, you know, on a yeah, OK,
we may get something like a, you know,
I am, yes.
along with that bin.
Group PCN number,
we may get a payer name of some sort and
a geography,
no actual associated claim with something
like that.
But essentially you know that that's
those are some of the metrics that would
come with with a claim.
So in reality,
what we're doing is we're not looking at
the number of claims or anything like
that.
We're trying to figure out the plan level
data that is tied to these claims.
OK,
so there are two buckets of input data.
One of them is RWD claims.
Straightforward, consistent format.
Yep.
You know what that looks like.
Sits in the table. We go to the table.
Yep.
The second bucket is anything people
throw at us.
Exactly. And and here's the reality,
right? In most cases,
the stuff that's getting thrown at us,
we can kind of,
we can tie it back to that same format
that we are looking at our own claims
currently.
OK.
OK, so that's the that's the very top.
That's everything that comes into this
Yep.
funnel, right?
And the first step of the funnel is a
Yep.
totally automated process that says have
I seen this exact data point before?
And if I has and it's already been
bridged.
Apply the MMIT plan ID. Move on.
Yeah. And what what I would like though,
you know, to think about is, you know,
along with that, right, is there,
if we build this thing out,
maybe just verify right somehow that that
bridging is still correct?
Hmm, OK.
OK,
so let's call that a some sort of QC
Yeah, yeah.
process. OK, may make a note about that.
The second step in the funnel is what you
call the fuzzy lookup.
So that's you know, if this word appears,
find you know the thing that that it
looks like you know some sort of string
matching metrics, blah blah blah.
And if that's above some,
there are rules that say if that's above
meets certain criteria,
we pass it through. If not,
then it goes to a manual pile.
Is that correct?
Yes.
OK. So that's there's certainly,
that's certainly an opportunity for us to
help I think.
And then the manual pile is there's an an
internal application that an analyst sits
down in front of and they get this piece
of information,
whether it's a claim ID or a spreadsheet
or something like that,
and they use that data in combination
with MIT plan data.
In combination with any other information
they want to do,
including Google searches to figure out
what MMIT plan IDs these items should be
linked to.
Is that correct?
Sorry, yes, correct.
And and right now that team,
OK.
so there's an operational team which does
the manual lookups and all that and they
have a a front end that they use to to do
that.
Right, right.
OK. And so the goals of trying to,
you know,
use some data science to improve this
process are improve the throughput at the
automated, the two automated stages.
And while keeping an eye on the quality
and then when we get to the manual stage,
try to help the analyst by making
suggestions about what is where this is
likely to go with some confidence level.
Yeah, I mean that in it's simple,
most simplistic form that that's exactly
it right is what what we're trying to do
is right now the way scripts are written
OK.
and the way the process works,
I think something like.
You know,
15% of records the tool will bridge for
us. The the expectation here is, you know,
we we don't think that we will ever get
to the point where 100% of records can be
automatically bridged.
Bridged, you know.
But if we can figure out a way even to
No, probably not. Yeah.
bridge 50% of those records automatically,
to me that's a huge win, right? That,
you know, we we've just.
Made the whole,
the process a whole lot more efficient
and essentially now that operations team
can do more, right? Because it, you know,
technically there's there's less on their
plate and we can do more,
we can do it faster, we can, you know,
get to market quicker.
The other piece of all this is,
I'm sure you're aware we are constantly
Mhm.
looking at who's the next, you know,
data vendor that we're going to bring in
when it comes to, you know,
our real-world data.
Um.
As it stands, the current process,
you know,
it would take something like four to five
years for us to to bridge or fully bridge
a new data set every time we bring on a
new vendor.
So it's it's a matter of prioritizing a,
you know,
we can bridge 80% of the volume a lot
quicker,
but all the what I call the onesies and
twosies,
which are just a couple claims here and
there and we've only seen this.
Particular insurance provider or whatnot,
you know, a few times.
Those are the ones that essentially take
forever.
Those are the ones that we have to go in
and do the Google and and all of that to
to figure out what it is.
You know, I've played around a little bit,
which is throwing one line of information.
Let's say it's a bin group PCN number or
whatnot,
like into something like ChatGPT and it
actually spits out results pretty.
You know, accurately most of the time.
So what what I'm trying to do is,
you know,
do we take kind of like a phased approach,
right,
where we write some scripts 1st and then
start figuring out how do we incorporate?
You know,
smart lookups or or smart suggestions and
things like that as kind of like a phase
two.
Yeah. So just to back up one step,
that 15% that you mentioned,
is that the first two steps,
the fully automated plus the fuzzy look,
fuzzy lookup?
Yeah, I mean, I I full transparency.
I I don't know exactly how the automated,
you know, bridging works now,
but I think it looks at, you know,
it's something like a payer name finds a
clue with that, right?
Like so we know it might be Aetna based
on the payer name.
So.
Then I think in the identification kind
of IDs at times that we receive or
whatnot,
it may look at like I mentioned before,
that ID may have something like you know,
NY medic in the identification which
would lead us.
To believe it's, you know,
like New York Medicaid. So there's,
you know,
kind of little little bits and pieces
Yeah, that that makes sense.
here that the system kind of looks at and
says, OK, we're, you know,
it's pretty confident that it's it's it.
Bridges to this particular plan or payer.
I'm assuming it probably works a little
bit differently when you're looking at
medical claims versus pharmacy claims,
just because in general pharmacy claims
at least tend to have a a bin group PCN
number, which helps us even.
You know, identify plans a little,
a little better. But like I said before,
it looks at things like, you know,
the naming conventions that may or may
not be provided.
It's looking at geography. You know,
Yeah, yeah.
in some cases I know there's scripts that
run that if we get a record.
With a specific patient ID and this time
you know there's no medical info or no
insurance information with that patient
ID.
What it does is it'll look back at like
where have we seen this patient ID before
and if we have, was there insurance on it?
And then it would apply that insurance to
that new record that was for whatever
reason missing the insurance information.
So that there's, you know,
a few scripts and processes that that are
running currently that help us identify
some things, but.
Again,
when it comes to the specific bridging,
you know I I keep referring.
I don't know if it's exactly a fuzzy look
up,
but it's probably like a fuzzy look up
plus, right?
Yeah, that's fine. I'm I'm more,
I'm trying to ask about the quantity that
Yeah.
that get successfully bridged at those
stages.
Yeah.
So you threw out this number 15% and so
I'm trying to understand if that's so
Yeah.
there's three phase,
there's three steps to this funnel.
There's fully automated,
there's fuzzy look up and there's manual.
So what?
Does the 15% represent the first phase,
the 1st 2 phases, the second phase?
I think it's it's probably the first two.
Um.
OK.
Which again, those scripts, like I said,
look at things like naming conventions,
which to me I equate to a fuzzy look up
and then some of the other kind of
Right.
Got it.
indicators.
OK.
And have you done any analysis to look at
error rates for that process?
Not that I'm aware of.
OK.
Do you have,
do you have a good understanding or an
Yeah, that this.
understanding of what the acceptable
error rates for automation would be?
No, I'm open to suggestions. So Jeremy,
like one, you know, one note here is,
OK.
you know,
I inherited a lot of this process.
So that's why I'm not, you know,
I can't sit here and and pinpoint exactly.
How everything works once we move forward.
Yeah, I mean we can get, you know,
That's fine. We can learn together.
like Will Vanderveer involved too,
because I think he had a hand in creating
this and but at this point, you know,
it's more of a, hey,
let's just discuss the the.
Part of what's possible.
Right. Yeah. I mean,
so that'll be something we'll have to
think about at some point. I mean,
the thing that strikes me off the bat is
like the the biggest lever,
I think the biggest lever we can pull is
in the automation phase.
Like I would focus on that first take,
Yeah.
take as much work off their plate as you
can, right?
100 percent, 100%.
Yeah,
and then when that when the juice isn't
worth the squeeze anymore, look at OK,
how can we make their work 10/20/30/40%
Yeah.
faster, right? Do you have examples?
So where this work has been done in the
past, is there?
A data store somewhere where that we can
go to where we can see, OK,
this thing came in,
it was automatically bridged because we'd
seen it. This thing came in,
it went through the Fuzzy lookup script
and it was matched to that.
This thing came in,
it wasn't matched to anything.
It went in front of an analyst.
The analyst did this.
Yeah, I'm sure we can.
We can get you some examples of, you know,
successful,
successfully automated versus you know,
kind of put into the queue for manual
review and.
And then what that looks like.
Yeah,
I think I would be interested much more
in some sort of data store or data stores
where we can go and get them versus
having colleagues, you know, pull,
pull them manually.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know what, George?
Ranker could probably provide some of
that. And between Ranker and maybe, uh,
Ashutosh.
OK.
Because I think I should touch can
probably, you know,
Uh.
discuss the UI a little further and and
provide some kind of wins and where these
things are stored. But yeah,
we'll we'll we'll get you something.
OK.
So and I think for now my this all makes
sense to me.
This all seems very logical and like a
good opportunity for us to, you know,
work together and improve the process.
I still don't have any insight as to what
happened at the planning session last
week.
So can you help Assan and I understand
where this sits in terms of priorities
and planning and you know,
should we be scoping this out?
Should we be waiting for things to be
approved budget wise like I don't have
any.
Is ability into that aspect.
Yeah, I think so. You know,
based on my understanding with with a lot
of the planning and and all that is this
would become a pretty high priority.
What Armahan had mentioned and I think
Hassan, you were on the call.
Is that he may even have some funding
potentially that that we can use for this
even in Q4, right?
If there's a a possibility to to do some
work here as far as priority wise and and
all of that, Jeremy, you know what I can.
Tell you is you know company-wide,
but even you know we'll we'll focus on
market access at MIT alone just about
every NPD that is being developed.
Mhm.
OK.
And integrating that together, well,
the most important, you know,
Um.
the foundation of all of that is the
actual bridging, right.
So if we can't bridge efficiently into
scale.
That that almost kind of puts everything
else at at, you know,
just delays everything right.
And so I think leadership is starting to
realize the importance or at least,
you know, kind of.
Putting putting some light onto the
importance of of all of this foundational
back end data integration work that that
needs to be done.
Mhm.
So I I think it's a it's going to be a
priority in 26 and based on that
discussion the reason we're.
We're talking now was Armahan
specifically said, hey, I may, you know,
if we can have a couple people that or
somebody that's available on a data
science team,
we may even be able to do some of or get
started on some of this work this year.
So Hassan, keep me honest there.
I think that's kind of where we landed
Yeah. So, so there is to clarify,
there's no one available readily per se.
with that.
However,
Armand did say that there is some funding
available. I'm also aware of that funding,
you know,
so for Q4 now of course that would
require hiring someone,
Yeah.
some consultant to take care of it.
Which is possible, right.
So what I would like to get to is you
know can we how quickly can we get to
actionable requirements that and if we
have a lot of so,
so Jeremy can start spending time with
you guys right on it.
Yeah.
And in concurrent to it or as soon as you
know we we can,
we can start looking for a resource that
can start at least start working on it in
Q4.
I'm not sure if we can deliver it will
all depend on the, you know,
complexity and the total amount of work
needed.
But we can absolutely start working now.
Yeah,
I don't think anybody expected us to
finish anything in Q4, but I think,
you know, the the thought was, hey,
if we can get started, let's get started.
Make sense?
Yeah.
So the single biggest next step that I
would need is access to those,
that historical data,
see what it looks like,
understand what's there and then I can
start turning that into requirements.
I can propose metrics and success targets
and send that back over to you for review.
But I think that's to me,
that's the next big thing.
Right, so.
Sh.
George, Hamrudra.
So here's what I'm thinking.
Maybe I'll set up a meeting something
like tomorrow with you guys and Jeremy
Yes.
and and ranker where at least we can at
the very start,
start with that automated process and I
think he could probably.
Probably guide us where things are,
what are the scripts look like and all of
that good stuff and and we could start
from there.
Sure but that works.
Mhm.
Yep. Thanks.
Yep, works for me.
All right,
well then look out for an a meeting
within the next couple days to to really
start digging in.
Right.
Oh.
Sounds that cool.
Cool. All right.
I think we even get 5 minutes back on
Whoa, is that possible?
this one.
OK.
All right, high five.
All right. Thank you very much, guys.
Thank you, Mani.
Thank you. Thank you so much. Yep. Bye.
Alright.
Cool. Alright, thanks. Bye. Alright,
bye bye.
Thanks. Bye.